madame la préfète monsieur le président
de l'assemblée des départements de
france madame la présidente du
département des bouches du rhône il sert
collègues parlementaires mes chers
collègues présidents de départements de
collectivités de métropole et des outre
mer chers collègues élus d'abord salué
un peu particulièrement vous ne m'en
voudrez pas benoît huré qui a fait un
choix judicieux mais qui lui a comme
disait pagnol fendu le coeur et oui ça
lui a fendu le coeur mais en même temps
je crois que le sénat va s'enrichir de
son expérience et cette semaine encore
il était à mes côtés dans une rencontre
pour me parler des préoccupations des
départements et j'y reviendrai dans un
instant salué les nouveaux présidents de
départements ils seront dans quelques
jours 22 où vous l'avez dit monsieur le
président
conséquence d'un texte j'y reviendrai
jaune dessus je ne suis pas sûr qu'il
soit porteur de liens dans le territoire
mais la réalité est assis et je dois le
dire que le sénateur d'octobre 2010 est
n'est plus le sénateur de juin 2017 et
qui va nous falloir inventer ce lien et
le renforcement de ce lien avec le
territoire
j'y reviendrai dans un instant j'ai
retenu des interventions d'andré viola
de françois sauvadet
avec benoît huré quelques mots clés
andré viola a parlé et c'est une
approche politique de boussole et de cap
il a pris l'image de la corde et je
pourrais prendre pour ce qu'il m'est
arrivé cet été
l'image du brouillard de la boussole et
du cap
il a posé le défi de la rupture et du
pacte républicain
hier viendrait mes chers collègues
n'oubliez pas au soir du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle la france
était divisée en quatre et la majorité
n'était pas aux formations politiques
d'héritage de l'alternance démocratique
il a parlé de méthodes et il a évoqué
décentralisation et autonomie françois
sauvadet a parlé de l'equilibre réserve
viendrait en écoutant le président de
meurthe et moselle
il y un instant entre métropole et
l'ensemble du territoire
il a parlé d' aménagement du territoire
politique disparu après un texte célèbre
en 1995 ça fait quand même 22 ans il a
parlé de décentralisation assumer en
fait j'ai peur qu'on écrive non pas
volpone mais le premier axe d'une
recentralisation
il a parlé de concertation et non pas de
consultation les interventions des
présidents de l'hérault et de la mayenne
nous ont démontré ce que dit d'ailleurs
alain lambert c'est qu'au fond c'est la
décision normatif la manière dont elle
se prend dont elle se construit jamais
évalué jamais revu et l'exemple d'un
pays qui a modifié son approche de la
décision normative comme les pays-bas
depuis bientôt 70 ans ça mérite qu'on y
réfléchisse et d'ailleurs c'est un des
engagements
je souhaite qu'ils soient tenues du
président de la république
j'y reviendrai dans un instant président
des hautes-alpes à parler de
l'extraordinaire explosion mais derrière
tout ça il ya la responsabilité de
l'état la question migratoire la
question pas simplement migratoires et
du développement et de l'equilibre le
continent je recevais il ya quelques
semaines président l'union africaine
mais quand on compare les chiffres du
président de l'union africaine aux
chiffres du secrétaire général de l'
ocde nous savons qu'aujourd'hui en
afrique il ya entre 70 millions et 90
millions de migrants et que leur
première destination c'est pas l'europe
c'est d'abord l'afrique elle-même et
notamment l'afrique du sud qui est en
train d'entrer dans une déstabilisation
outre politique et financière dans une
déstabilisation j'allais dire à
caractère ethno racial la proximité des
départements président saviez c'est bien
qu'il y à peu un versailles
nous nous sommes retrouvé un certain
nombre pour évoquer cette question parce
que je crois profondément à la proximité
et la proximité ce n'est pas qu'une
question rural c'est aussi une question
pour l'ensemble des territoires
emilien hermeline malherbe va parler
d'autonomie sur la question des emplois
aidés j'y reviendrai sur la question des
péréquations chers collègues simplement
évaluons bien avant d'entrer dans des
systèmes dont on mesure parfois quelques
années après qu'ils sont déstabilisants
l'exemple de quelques régions notamment
celle que je connais plus
particulièrement pour en être un élu
m'amène à penser qu'il faut être sur ce
sujet et son lapin en fait on n'a pas
bougé sur le président n'a pas bougé
depuis une première tentative de réforme
en 2008 2009 et donc c'est un sujet
qui est devant nous enfin je suis le
président du cantal
c'est vrai quand on regarde la loi de
l'autre les contrats de plan demain
devrait déférer parce qu'ils sont
contraires à la loi et donc il va bien
falloir se poser la question de la place
et des uns et des autres alors mes chers
collègues
c'est vrai que je suis heureux d'être
ici c'est votre 87e congrès il ya lieu
dans sa département une ville qui sont
aussi un symbole symboles de la
république
ça vole aussi de l'ouverture vers les
défis du des continents d'en face ça
s'appelle l'afrique ou qui s'appelle
lorient c'est aussi un moment important
parce que les présidents l'ont dit ce
fut une année marquée par une séquence
électorale danse un nouveau président de
la république
une nouvelle assemblée nationale et le
renouvellement du sénat
ouais vous le rappeler mes chers
collègues le sénat ne procède pas
d'élection présidentielle c'est
d'ailleurs depuis la réforme du
quinquennat
je ne suis pas certain que ce fut lui
des la plus géniale que nous ayons eu
comme j'ai participé j'assume ma part et
bien je le dis est la seule institution
qui ne procèdent pas que cette élection
je le dois vous dire que fort de sa
légitimité renforcée mais j'allais dire
aussi de sa diversité
car pour moi aucun des trois cent
quarante sept sénateurs que j'ai eu le
grand honneur de présider ne doit pas
contribué à cette représentation des
collectivités territoriales je les dis
clairement nous ne sommes pas un anti
pouvoir
mais nous sommes solidaires un contre
nous ne disons jamais non par dogmatisme
mais jamais oui par discipline partisane
en tous les cas c'est ma manière d'être
et je crois que nous avons aussi temps
une responsabilité spécifique
on nous parle beaucoup de mondialisation
je n'ose plus prononcé le mot nouveau
monde puisque les vikings il avait
découvert un an qu'on pense que ce soit
un nouveau monde je vous propose d'être
liqing en quelque sorte de
l'anticipation du nouveau monde
oui nous représentons me semble-t-il ce
que vous êtes
c'est à dire une france de la vie
concrète des français au quotidien et je
crois que cet équilibre des territoires
il ne doit pas opposer les territoires
les uns aux autres mais dire que chacun
joue un rôle majeur dans la cohésion du
pays
votre congrès intervient également trois
mois après la conférence nationale des
territoires au cours de laquelle le
gouvernement le matin vous étiez présent
incertain ans puis le président de la
république l'après midi se sont engagés
dans la restauration de la confiance et
l'engagement d'un dialogue y compris à
le sud pour constater les accords et les
désaccords mais dialogue préalable
recherche d'accords et puis quand il n'y
a pas d'accord il peut y avoir des
désaccords constaté trois mois qui je le
dis sans esprit polémique ont fait
apparaître une divergence entre discours
et actes trois mois qui ont suffit à
nourrir les inquiétudes sur l'avenir des
collectivités territoriales et cela je
l' ai ressenti très fort sur le terrain
en visitant une vingtaine de
départements
notre naturellement je travaillais à
compte d'auteur vous comprendrez
pourquoi
mais en même temps quand je suis dans le
département de l'orne un certain 21 août
pleine période de vacances que je vois
autour de la thématique de la commune
nouvelle
autant d'élus présents quand je m'en
vais à l'aigle l'après midi que je vois
un nouveau maire
élu un mois et demi avant il était
conseiller délégué qui dit l'an dernier
le sous préfet venait me supplier de
faire des contrats aidés
il y adeux m'annoncer qu'il n'y en aura
plus à partir du mois de novembre
voilà la réalité et cette réalité c'est
une question de méthode
alors mes chers collègues nous avons eu
souvent l'occasion d'échanger sur
l'avenir des collectivités territoriales
sur l'avenir du département
plus que jamais comme vous pas pour vous
faire plaisir pas parce que je suis
devant votre congrès pas parce que je
suis à marseille je pense que nos
concitoyens ont besoin d'efficacité et
de proximité et le département reste le
bon niveau de collectivité pour assurer
une mission fondamentale être le pivot
des politiques territoriales notamment
de solidarité entre les personnes et les
territoires au fond le département comme
la commune est inscrit
j'allais dire au coeur quotidien des
français qui lui témoigne un réel
attachement
il fait chaque jour la preuve de sa
pertinence en répondant à ses besoins de
proximité qu'il s'agisse de politique
sociale collèges de route de politiques
culturelles madame la présidente des
bouches du rhône de politique
touristique
j'ai bien aimé votre formule que vous
êtes un accélérateur de changement avec
la commune le département et notre
collectivité la plus ancienne mais je
crois profondément
andré viola que et les modernes et les
modernes comme collectivité
bien sûr remanier profondément à partir
des doigts de décentralisation de 82 83
puis celle conduite par jacques chirac
et jean pierre raffarin puis par les
réformes territoriales successifs qui en
dépit parfois des attaques
on toujours consacré sa place conclusion
de volpone le département est un échelon
pertinent je le disais un instant
matière d'aménagement du territoire
situé à juste distance entre régions
communes et intercommunalités et puisque
le puy-de-dôme le cantal se sont
découvert une frontière commune avec la
suisse il m'apparaît extrêmement
important que le seul pivot depuis
fights lyon ou des communes un peu isolé
mais bien être un département qui joue
ce rôle d'interface
je voudrais insister poule avec 10 dans
sa routine des missions qu'il faudra
développer à l'image d'un certain nombre
de vos départements
c'est le rôle d'ingénierie publique avec
les communes et les intercommunalités
je peux vous dire que là où ça
fonctionne
les résultats sont assez exceptionnelles
et sont une occasion jaillir de
relations parfois j'allais dire
fusionnelle presque entre cette
ingénierie publique à la condition
qu'elle se fasse dans les respects des
communes aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui comme hier mon attitude est
identique rejeter toute approche
idéologique technocratique de pure
communication que ce soit sur le nombre
d'élus locaux ou sur un nombre de
collectivités qui serait pertinent et
notamment deux départements supprimer
comme on l'a entendu un quart des
départements pour répondre à une
politique du chiffre
ça n'est pas l'objectif du sénat par
conte laissons faire les initiatives de
rapprochement de coopération de fusion
quand elles sont souhaitées qui viennent
du territoire un peu comme pour les
communes nouvelles
l'expérience du grand ouest est
intéressante à analyser sur ce point
mais cessons et c'est un président de
l'assemblée parlementaire qui vous le
dit c'est son d'attendre tout de la loi
ou de tout subir de la loi et de
demander des uns et les autres toujours
plus de lois
je crois que nous devons avoir une
approche quelque peu différente
je crois bien sûr indispensable de vous
donner les moyens d'agir et de faciliter
des projets de coopération
je pense aux mutualisation ayant un
nouveau directeur de cabinet m'a rappelé
la mutualisation entre en indre et loire
loir et cher entre la savoie et la haute
savoie
je pourrais aussi lui parler de
l'eure-et-loir et du loiret je pourrais
lui parler aussi de ce qui se passe
entre des yvelines et des hauts-de-seine
mais je pense que c'est à l'initiative
des élus et non pas de l'état que ce
mouvement doit se faire éloigner
pourquoi l'état des réalités concrètes
j'ai tenu à transmettre au président de
la république un message qui m'a été
délivrés lors de mes déplacements dans
les départements cours des derniers
douze derniers mois il faut laisser le
temps aux élus de digérer et de mettre
en oeuvre les réformes puis de se
projeter
ceci n'exclut pas les aménagements
monsieur le président que vous avez
évoqué d'alwan autres n'est pas une loi
de décentralisation
ce n'est pas non plus un totem
même si nous pensons qu'il faut en
préserver l'économie générale on va
quand même pas se faire une réforme tous
les cinq ans jeudi devant le président
du conseil départemental de haute saône
qui nous avait aidés à réfléchir au
sénat il ya quelques années mais il faut
savoir être pragmatique procéder aux
ajustements nécessaires
ce sera l'attitude du sénat et le
président bussereau a évoqué le rapport
de mathieu darnaud mais aussi de rené
vandierendonck qui est un rapport
conjoint sur à la fois les sons
respirait des territoires mais en
mettant ajustons lahoud
nécessaire le sénat doit donc
aujourd'hui contribuer à réinstaurer à
restaurer la confiance et le respect
dans les relations entre l'état les
collectivités territoriales
je les dis samedi dernier en tête à tête
au président de la république et je le
dis là aussi avec la volonté construire
car j'ai tellement envie que mon pays
réussissent on ne redressera pas la
france sans ou contre les collectivités
territoriales
[Applaudissements]
une faux il faut que cessent ces
rendez-vous raté entre le gouvernement
et nos associations d'élus j'espère que
demain à marseille en face du vieux port
ce sera mieux qu'à orléans et mieux qu'à
nantes
c'est vraiment ce que j'ai dit au
président c'est ce que j'ai dit au
premier ministre
j'allais dire au delà de toute approche
politicienne
on ne peut pas continuer dans cette
césure entre collectivités territoriales
et exécutif
je leur ai dit il ne peut y avoir de
pacte de confiance sans respect réel des
élus locaux s'étaient d'ailleurs ma
conclusion du 17 juillet dernier
on ne peut pas ne passer par pertes et
profits
l'article 72 de notre constitution qui
inclut chère martine vassal la liberté
de gestion y compris
y compris quand il s'agit de la question
des personnels sujet pas simple sujet
facile à faire en congrès pas simple à
réaliser
sall ancien ministre du travail qui vous
dit ça il faudra monsieur sauvadet
croyance qui est la vôtre à la fois de
la confiance du respect et un temps de
dialogue approfondi mais c'est vrai que
l'annulation de 300 millions d'euros de
crédit au cours de l'été trois jours
après la conférence nationale des
territoires ça a été une rupture de
méthodes et je ne reviendrai pas sur les
contrats aidés depuis le dialogue a
repris je le sais et j'ai essayé d'y
contribuer et maintenant comme vous
j'attends les preuves concrètes en
direction des collectivités car je
voudrais affirme un conseiller national
des territoires ce peut être une vraie
méthode de dialogue et pas simplement de
consultation
vous l'avez dit les uns les autres je
veux être clair à nouveau devant vous
nul ne conteste la nécessité absolue
d'assainir les finances publiques
c'est une exigence qui s'impose à tous
toutes les entités publiques les
collectivités locales en font partie
mais et s'équilibrait au regard des
efforts déjà consentis depuis cinq ans
connaissait la réponse
nos rapports de la cour des comptes sur
les finances locales publié la semaine
passée confirme les progrès réalisés par
les collectivités territoriales dans
dépenses ont diminué de plus de 1%
elles ont pu afficher un excédent de
plus de 4 milliards d'euros et en même
temps pour l'état or est un déficit de 3
4% du pipe et nous devrons encore chers
collègues emprunter 195 milliards l'an
prochain sur les marchés financiers
voilà la réalité que nous aurons à yves
des progrès en matière d'efficacité de
la dépense sont encore je le pense
parfois possible mais ceux réalisés ces
dernières années ne sont pas
reproductibles indéfiniment voilà
pourquoi le chiffre de 1,2 pour cent je
le dis me paraît peu réaliste et ne pas
tenir compte d'ailleurs de la diversité
il faudra bien que nous ayons une
approche et pas simplement dans nos
autres maires de la différenciation et
de l'expérimentation
ce n'est pas agir contre l'unité de la
république que d'avoir cette approche
ces efforts ne sont pas équilibrées non
plus dans l'absolu les collectivités
territoriales tout ensemble confondues
c'est 20 % de la dépense publique
or la programmation qui est soumise au
parlement prévoit qu'en fait de
contribution à un tiers de l'effort
global le gouvernement
engagez vous l'avez évoqué les uns des
autres une contractualisation financière
avec les collectivités
mais pourquoi pas mais cela doit
s'opérer sur la base d'un constat
partagé
je rappelle que la philosophie d'un
contrat dans le code civil c'est un
accord de volonté que chacun est libre
de contracter ou de ne pas contracter
c'est dans le code civil pour le contrat
et que les contrats doivent être
négociées formés et exécutées de bonne
foi fin de citation du code civil
la contractualisation sous la menace
n'est pas une contractualisation qui
d'ailleurs respecte la constitution
ce serait une forme en fait de
recentralisation rampante et je ne vois
pas le président bussereau allez
demander l'autorisation préalable de
présenter son budget ça nous renvoie des
périodes antérieures
avant de le soumettre à son assemblée
délibérante
un mot pardon d'être long mais on va
rentrer dans le concret dans quelques
jours action sociale ça cassait que le
département est le meilleur échelon de
proximité pour l'action sociale
encore faut-il qu'on respecte son
autonomie dans la gestion de prestations
bien sûr la question du rsa les
départements démontrer la pertinence de
leurs actions en matière d'insertion et
il faut leur faire confiance
et monsieur le président mes chers
collègues vous savez qu'il ya une
tentation très fortes notamment le long
de la seine dans un immeuble construit
il ya 25 ans à recentraliser de rsa j'ai
dit au président de la république
comment on peut imaginer une assertion
recentraliser alors qu'aujourd'hui on
imagine une formation professionnelle
confié aux régions
pourquoi parce qu'il faut de la
proximité des réalités et que dans les
ardennes par exemple ça n'est pas la
même situation qu'en côte-d'or où que
dans les yvelines
voilà pourquoi il est d'utilité publique
que vous conserviez cette dimension de
l'insertion de cette proximité
alors mes chers collègues l'autre sujet
que vous avez évoqué les mineurs isolés
je ne reviens pas sur les chiffres
cette question n'est pas que budgétaire
elle était aussi une question
d'humanisme
elle est aussi une question de politique
régaliennes rapport du sénat d'elisabeth
doisneau et jean pierre godefroy non
souligné en juin dans le cadre de un
rapport sur les mineurs d'un accompagné
cas de grande détresse
mais en même temps
j'ai rencontré les travailleurs sociaux
dans le désarroi est immense il ne peut
plus remplir en font leur mission
d'accompagnement et de suivi pour
assurer à ces jeunes et notamment aux
jeunes qui historiquement a été confiée
à cette action que vous conduisez pour
l'enfance ils sont aujourd'hui
simplement à faire de la mise sous abri
de l'accueil et un certain nombre de
situations conduiront à des tensions
dramatiques
je le dis dans un certain nombre de
territoires
voilà pourquoi j'ai demandé
solennellement au président de la
république que ce qui est de
responsabilités régaliennes soient
assumés par l'état pas simplement pour
renvoyer la dépense mais parce que la
question migratoire est un sujet majeur
qu'elle ne doit pas évacuer les valeurs
que nous portons les valeurs humanistes
et d'accueil
mais quand même temps quand on voit les
chiffres que le département des
hautes-alpes nous donner en illustration
je faisais moi-même le compte y est 20
fois plus d'une année à l'autre de ne se
pas se poser des questions de fond
qu'elle soit au plan européen et au plan
français alors mes chers collègues deux
tiers de vos dépenses ont constitué par
les dépenses sociales
je pense que le travail que nos
collègues lecerf fedak verts ont fait
est qu'un travail sur lequel on peut
puiser et tous ensemble
la compensation versée par l'état
aujourd'hui vous l'avez dit est
totalement insuffisante
le président de la république s'est
engagé devant vous je ne suis pas là
pour lui faire des rappels à l'ordre
j'ai simplement dit au président après
m'être entretenu avec dominique
bussereau qu'il était indispensable qu'à
la foire on est le fonds d'urgence au
moins temporairement et qu'il va falloir
réintroduire dans la loi de finances
avant qu'il solution puisse être trouvée
dans les délais sur lequel le président
de la république
s'est engagée c'est à dire avant la fin
du premier semestre de 2018
c'est me semble-t-il pour le parlement
une responsabilité à vos côtés et
notamment nous saigne acquis article 24
de la constitution avant la
responsabilité de vous représenter
collectivités territoriales de la
république
un nouveau mode de financement adaptées
père elle doit être trouvé la
proposition consistant à opérer un
transfert de cg pour couvrir les
dépenses de solidarité des départements
vous l'avez évoqué elle me semble une
piste intéressante
maintenant à évaluer financé par un
impôt national des dépenses dont les
principaux déterminants sont fixés au
niveau central
sur proposition de l'exécutif par le
parlement me semble a priori faire sens
cette perspective s'inscrirait dans le
cas d'une remise à plat de la fiscalité
locale qui respecterait l'autonomie
financière des différentes collectivités
et en dehors de ré justement 2018
le débat qui va s'ouvrir sur la taxe
d'habitation mais aussi sur le foncier
bâti
parce que ce qui est un hymne équitable
en matière de valeurs locatives les
autant pour le foncier bâti sur la taxe
d'habitation doit être l'occasion
d'ouvrir un débat plus général sur la
fiscalité locale et les ressources
c'est ce qu'avait entamé la commission
des finances sous l'autorité la halle
berry de montgolfier que vous connaissez
un peu et de michel andré qui
aujourd'hui est repris par albéric de
montgolfier et vincent eblé
je vous rejoins cette étape cher
dominique bussereau de remise à niveau
elle est indispensable elle doit être
intégrée dans toute approche
contractuelle équilibre des territoires
en un mot bien sûr comme le président de
meurthe-et-moselle
je partage l'idée qu'il ne faut pas
opposer les métropoles ou territoires
que les métropoles peuvent être une
chance pour le pays
mais je voudrais vous livrer ce cas
l'élu du pas de calais ma vie dit que
j'avais pris en pleine poire
il ya un an et demi monsieur le
président pourquoi vous faites que des
lois pour quelques métropoles et
quelques régions puissante et bien je
crois que ce questionnement si c'était
qu'il est vrai comme nous avons le génie
en france de multiplier les métropoles
comme on a multiplié sur dominique à une
époque les pôles de compétitivité
nous arrivons quand même à une
définition de la métropole qui s'éloigne
singulièrement de ce que doit être une
métropole au sens européen
et si chacun veut avoir sa métropole
je réclame que rambo this deviennent
métropole et alors je vous le dis il
faut garder raison sur ces sujets nous
deux on garder raison sur ces sujets
voilà pourquoi le sénat très largement
et au delà des attentes légitimes de tel
ou tel d'être métropole ce pop se poser
la question est ce qu'on donnerait tout
pour les uns et les autres ne serait
rien mes chers collègues on a une
responsabilité politique je reviens au
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle est ce qu'on veut
vraiment continuer à désespérer nos
concitoyens est-ce qu'on va vraiment de
redonner le sentiment d'être à côté
est ce qu'on veut vraiment leur donner
sentiments par exemple ils compris dans
le nord de leur aide war ou dans le sud
des yvelines de l'essonne de
seine-et-marne
quand vous avez je parle tous francs des
villages qui donne 50 60 % au front
national
est-ce que ça n'est pas une question qui
est posée parce qu'ils ont le sentiment
de ne plus compter de ne plus être
entendu voilà pourquoi la proximité
quelque chose d'essentiel à mes yeux
oui comment se sentir pleinement
intégrée à la nation quand on a le
sentiment que l'état vous abandonne
comment avoir le sentiment d'être
intégré à la nation quand on a
la sensation d'être laissé de côté parce
qu'on n'habite pas au bon endroit
je ne reviendrai pas mais sur les
divisions qu'on nous propose parfois
dans des grandes régions comme
l'ile-de-france au fond 7 millions
d'habitants qui sont 80% du pipe serait
séparé de 5 millions d'habitants qui
sont un pour cent du pipe c'est une
conception pardonnez moi qui est
contraire à la solidarité territoriale
alors ya bien d'autres sujets le sujet
des ruptures d'égalité en matière de
couverture numérique des territoires
dray et sujet vrai sujet parce qu'il
n'ya pas de développement de bain il n'y
a pas de présence territoriale sur cela
voilà pourquoi j'ai saisi le président
de l'arcep pour que les propos devant le
conseil national du territoire du
président de la république haut et très
haut débit en 2020 comment ça se traduit
concrètement comment le met en oeuvre
alors qu'en même temps un grand
opérateur temps de bouleverser la
répartition les équilibres qui ne sont
pas les meilleurs payeurs
comment on fait face à cette tentative
uniquement un caractère commercial et
capitalistique
comment comment gèrent les ruptures
d'égalité en matière d'accès aux soins
en matière de transport quand vous dire
que l'avant projet de paix est la fessée
c'est intéressant sur ce point on évalue
les dispositifs d'incitation lève les
freins au développement de la
télémédecine on favorise les nouveaux
modes d'exercice ont fait du stage de 6
voir ce qui me semble encore un peu
court de l'étudiant en médecine générale
généraliste un passage obligé mais je
vois tellement départements qui sont
dans des perspectives de présence
médicale terrible il ya dans un
département en moins de 150 km de paris
et dans un à 120 km de paris deux fois
moins de médecins généralistes que dans
mon département par tête d'habitant
si ce n'est pas une question
d'égalité d'équité et de confiance dans
le territoire alors ça n'est pas une
question il ya aussi ce qui me frappe
dans beaucoup de territoires
c'est l'anorexie des centres bourgs des
petites villes et de certaines villes
moyennes
quand je parle d'anorexie vous avez un
symptôme
les rideaux sont baissés 1 sur 2 2 sur 3
dans beaucoup de ces connu on ne pourra
pas continuer simplement autour de cinq
grandes plateformes de distribution à
imaginer ce que doit être la présence du
commerce et des services dans nos
territoires
voilà pourquoi la délégation
collectivités territoriales dans
quelques semaines vous fera des
propositions mais il faut que ça sorte
jaillir du seul rapport pour rentrer
réellement en action voilà mes chers
collègues un peu en désordre et pas du
tout en fonction ce qu'on m'avait
préparé ce que j'avais envie de vous
dire vous dire que naturellement le
sénat sera monsieur le président à votre
disposition mais que nous allons vous
proposer comme autres deux autres
associations de participer concrètement
à notre délégation collectivités
territoriales que nous avons mis en
place par l'intermédiaire des sénateurs
un service pour les collectivités
territoriales et notamment pour les
communes service qui est aujourd'hui
pleinement fonctionnelle mais comment
aussi nous allons mettre en place une
plate forme de consultation des élus et
cette consultation se sevrer
c'est pour faire de la concertation
préalablement au tec
alors vous avez tous en tête mais comme
ça se déroulait dans une des villes dont
je suis le sénateur ce mode mirabeau
c'était le 3 9 en 1789
c'était à versailles je voudrais une
division propre localité aux
circonstances dont l'objet fut de
rapprocher l'administration des hommes
et des choses
héguy admettre un plus grand concours de
citoyens je sais pas le président cissé
l'ancien au nouveau monde mais je sais
que c'était le renouveau de la
démocratie et que le renouveau de la
démocratie
il a commencé avec deux structures les
départements et les communes
alors je vous le dis je crois au
département pas simplement vous faire
plaisir ce matin parce que je sens
profondément que notre pays a besoin de
cette proximité
la vive le département vive la
république vive la france
[Applaudissements]